sir david was well known for a number of
causes close to his heart
not least the treatment of animals for
which he was famous and he was also a
spirited campaigner supporter of many
other charities
he is speaking at the royal albert hall
a couple of years back at a concert
organized by the music man project
where by the way i myself was present a
charity he passionately supported as
patron
it's been enjoyed
by you
the family and friends and relatives
and i can only just begin to imagine
how each and every one of you
must be bursting with pride
at what these people have achieved
tonight
[Applause]
i can now speak to the founder and chief
executive of that charity david stanley
who
lives in lyon sea um
david uh
the thing that struck me most on
that day that that concert was that
david amos seemed to know everybody in
the place and this is royal albert hall
absolutely trevor um
there we were at the albert hall 3 000
people and hundreds performing the vast
majority
musicians from the music man project and
yet sir david amos
was in his elements waving speaking to
everybody
everybody knew sir david
and
on that night he was just beaming with
pride
because
the dream of having
a huge capacity audience watching
musicians with learning disabilities
inspire
that audience that iconic venue
had come true and largely that was
thanks to the help from sir david
can you tell us a bit about
how he worked with you
his involvement in the charity
yes well i mean i've known sir david for
over 25 years initially just as a
musician in in his
constituency
and then after a while he he lent his
support to uh to my work and he would
always ask me
david what can i do to help what can i
do to help you fulfill your dreams
how can i help your charity
all the time that's what he would say
and
for me that was to
open doors you see i'm a musician and a
teacher
but sir david amos had the access the
the influence
to campaign for my charity for greater
opportunities and you must remember that
only a few decades ago people with
learning disabilities would have been
hidden away
there's no
real chance for them to change their
destiny and to create opportunities like
that and we went on this journey
together and he opened doors that i
couldn't open he
he campaigned he fundraised he he just
told everybody and we had this wonderful
way of coming up with grand ideas and
grand plans
the london palladium breaking a world
record performing to members of the
royal family and ultimately the albert
hall and
you know we were then going to go on and
try and get a concert tour to broadway
he was such an exciting man to know
because i always felt that everything
was possible with sir david and
he was just so proud of south end
you are in leoncy which is uh just a
little bit outside of south andan um in
fact i lived in leon sea for a little
while when i worked at an
oil refinery along the estuary it's a
very quiet place it's a dormitory town
um it's possibly the last place you
would have
imagined something like this happening
what impact do you think it's going to
have on leon c
well i mean it's just a devastating
shock
but i think as the days and the weeks
and the months go by
i i do feel as if the the town
and particularly the leon sea part of
south end
will sadly have changed
it is on on all of us to try and make
sure that we continue that positive
legacy of sir david
but you're right this is a peaceful
town a peaceful part of of south end and
it's just so tragic
that
someone so great
someone that
has done so much for his people
well in a sense we're now going to be
remembered
for such a tragedy
and
i think that is probably one of the most
awful aspects of this
david um
you're right we probably don't want to
remember
him
for what happened on friday though to
some extent that's going to be
unavoidable but if you
were to
if you like
pen
the legacy of sir david amos as somebody
who's known him a long time who lived
locally in his constituency
what would you want it to be
well so much but i think probably
a champion of people
the champion of south end
but most of all an outstanding
constituency mp
that seemed to me
to be happier serving his people
helping his people than anything else in
his life
and
the legacy
must be
city status if we can
the legacy
must be the continuation of his work for
his charities but most of all
i want to remember him for the person
who
stood up for the people
that were vulnerable
that were difficult to reach
that were the people that often were
left behind
and that is perhaps what people don't
know so much about sir david amos
david stanley thank you very much indeed